AWKWARD FAMILY PHOTOS.
>> AWKWARD FAMILY PHOTOS.COM HAS
BUILT AN EMPIRE OF PICTURES THAT
FAMILIES WILL SPEND THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES WISHING NEVER
EXISTED.
BUT LUCKILY THEY DO.
COMEDIANS FOR 250 POINTS I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO CAPTION THESE FAMILY
PHOTOS, ALL RIGHT? VERY SIMPLE.
>> FIRST ONE, THIS GUN LOVING
CLAN.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN A BABY LOOK
MORE FRIGHTENED IN MY LIFE.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN A BABY THAT
SHOULD LOOK MORE FRIGHTENED.
>> Chris: WHAT IS THE CAPTION.
>> THERE USED TO BE MORE OF US.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> Chris: MARIA.
>> WE ARE THE COWARDS, WE DON'T
KNOW HOW TO USE OUR WORDS.
>> Chris: NICE.
I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS FOR THAT.
GUNS DON'T KILL PEOPLE, THESE
PEOPLE KILL PEOPLE.
>> I WONDER WHAT FAMILY THEY'RE
FIGHTING AGAINST.
>> Chris: IF YOU OPEN A PHOTO
OUT IT IS THE MCCOYS ON THE
OTHER SIDE.
ALL RIGHT NEXT ONE.
THIS VIOLENTLY DOMESTICATED
FAMILY.
>> GRRR.
>> IT'S SO FUNNY WHEN I CHOKE
THEM. JACKIE.
NACO LIBRE.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
I THINK A BETTER PICTURE WOULD
BE HIM TRYING TO GET HIS HANDS
AROUND THEIR WAISTS.
(BLEEP). DAMN.
>> IF DADDY DOESN'T KILL US TYPE
2 DIABETES WILL.
>> AH.
>> Chris: I FEEL BAD BUT THE
AUDIENCE WANTS ME TO GIVE YOU
POINTS, SO YOU GET 'EM.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> YOU ARE BAD PEOPLE! YOU ARE
BAD PEOPLE! YOU SHOULD FEEL
BAD! YOU ARE JUST FUELING THE
FIRES OF HOW BAD YOU ARE!
>> WELL, THAT WAS GREAT.
THAT WAS GREAT.
>> Chris: DARK EVIL HEARTS OF
THIS AUDIENCE SO POINTS FOR YOU,
MARIA BAMFORD.
NEXT ONE, HOW ABOUT THESE
PROBABLY NOT VERY FIT PARENTS.
>> YES, TOMMY.
>> IT LOOKS SO DIFFERENT FROM
THE OUTSIDE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> IT MUST BE REAL SPECIAL IF
YOU HAVE TO WEAR A BOW TIE TO GO
IN THERE.
>> WHO KNEW IT WAS SEMIFORMAL.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ONE.
THIS FIERY FAMILY.
>> OH.
>> Chris: YES, TOMMY.
>> I DIDN'T KNOW THE FLATTOPS
WERE HEREDITARY.
>> Chris: THEY ARE, YEP.
IF THEY REALLY WANTED TO MAKE
THIS PICTURE AWESOME THEY WOULD
ALL HAVE FLATTOPS.
BUT, NO.
YOU HAVE POINTS.
MARIA.
>> WE ARE FINE, EVERYTHING IS
FINE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> WE ARE JUST HANGING OUT AND
MAKING OUT IN THE CRAB NEBULA.
>> YES.
JACKIE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE OUT
DURING THE RAPTURE.
>> Chris: YES.
GOOD.
POINTS.
HOW ABOUT THIS LAST ONE, THESE
PARENT TO BE?
>> I DON'T FEEL GOOD RIGHT NOW.
>> Chris: JACKIE?
>> HORIZONTAL STRIPES DO WHAT?
>> Chris: POINTS.
MARIA.
>> HONEY, I CAN FEEL IT KILLING
FROM THE INSIDE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> DOCTOR? THIS BABY IS GOING TO
(BLEEP)ING DELIVER ITSELF.
>> WHEN DID HOT TOPIC GET A
MATERNITY SECTION.